[Music]
we're white against km gd
8 1685 let's go with an e4 and we'll
decide what to do
okay so we've been playing the danish
gambit we've been playing the vienna
gambit
you know we've been playing we played
the scotch gambit once
and let's play another danish and let's
see how somebody at like a 1700 level
reacts
to to a danish well
danishes are great oh knight c6 okay so
that's that answers your question
danish gamut was declined so knight c6
is
not a bad move this transposes basically
into a nimsovich opening
usually this occurs via the move order
knight c6 here
d4 e5 and
we've faced this a couple of times
before
and as you guys know i prefer the center
to be open so d5 here is extremely
tempting
because it occurs with tempo but as i've
explained previously closing down the
center like this is not quite as
beneficial for white as it seems
and it's a better idea to take on e5 and
get this knight
to move twice in the opening as we also
discussed
some people would not go for this
because the night is centralized and
one could say well aren't we helping
black centralized his night but
thank you rhapsodiomas for the five but
that's you know
not a good representation of the
situation because the knight on e5
as a standalone piece is very vulnerable
we can chase the knight away with f4
uh we can offer a trade with knight f3
so the fact that the knight is
centralized isn't important
and the move f4 is okay but i don't love
it because it it's very exposing it
exposes the king
the knight's gonna drop back to c6 and
later on black will bring the bishop out
to c5 and stop us from castling
so between f4 and knight f3 i prefer to
play knight f3
but before we even play knight f3
there's a way to develop a little bit
more flexibly what is a more flexible
move let's see
how black develops his pieces before we
decide because maybe
we'll want i mean if he goes knight f6
then f4 becomes quite a bit stronger
so let's start with the move knight c3
and you'll see that if he plays knight
f6 okay plays bishop b4 which is good
and you know now we first need to figure
out
are we afraid of him taking on c3 is
that a scary possibility
okay so that's not a scary possibility
not particularly
we don't really mind our our queen side
pawn structure getting damaged because
we're probably going to castle king's
side
there's a couple of interesting options
here the first thing i see is that the
bishop and the knight are both
undefended so there's kind of a typical
idea in these types of situations to
exploit that
and that's the move queen to d4 so let's
calculate after queen d4
he does have a way of defending both
pieces at the same time now he's got
several ways of doing that
he can drop the knight back to c6 but
clearly that would blunder the g7 pawn
he could drop the bishop back to d6 but
that would be a huge win for us
his he could take the knight on c3 that
would also be a big win for us
and then there's one more move that he
could play let's see if he finds it
and that's the move queen to e7 that's
the reason why queen
d4 is often not a good move in these
types of situations but this
there is an extenuating factor here
what is that factor what move do we have
after queen e7 now this is a little bit
risky
we're violating some opening rules we're
not developing our pieces as quickly as
we could be
we're trying to exploit a temporary
flaw in the way that he's developed his
pieces
so we have to notice here the fact that
the g7 pawn is vulnerable we can't move
our knight the knight is pinned
and this knight on e5 we can chase it
away with the move
f4 now the move bishop f4 would not be
as effective because then he could
no d6 would blunder the bishop but he
could play perhaps the move f6
and um and that would be fine for him
the move f4 forces his knight to move
you know he can't
prop the knight up this is a lot less
clear than it appears if he plays this
correctly i think black is fine here but
let's see if he's able to
make sense of these complications oh his
best move here would be knight g6
and the reason why is that if he moves
the knight to c6
and we take on g7 the rook is going to
be hanging
if he moves the knight to g6 and we take
on g7 the rook is not going to be hanged
the knight is going to defend the rook
so his hands are going to be untied he's
going to have a tempo
to do what he wants to do he finds it
very nicely done
so i don't particularly like the idea of
taking on g7 because
he has a nasty response
in the form of yeah yes queen f6 but
then we'd be upon up
actually maybe i do like this i'm trying
to calculate it myself
yeah he's got no not f6 he's got queen
takes e4
check and we can't take the queen
because of the pin that's a nasty little
check
and then c2 is going to be hanging so
that leads to a complete mess
but there's a very interesting idea that
i just spotted
so let's take it anyway and assuming he
takes on e4
i'll be able to show you guys what i'm
thinking
so this is extremely risky and
i kind of okay so most people here i
assume
would be tempted to block the check
bishop e2 or maybe 92 because moving the
king in the opening
is generally pretty unthinkable but
there is an exception here
because if we block the check first of
all if we block it with the knight well
how are we going to develop our bishop
and second of all
that pawn on c2 is hanging we don't
really want to give that pawn away
because that's going to make it hard to
develop this bishop there's going to be
a cascade effect also
the queen is pinned which is kind of
annoying as well so i like the move king
d1 here it
it opens up the attack on the queen and
most importantly it opens up the e file
and there's gonna be a race
to get my rook to the e file if i'm able
to do that
and he's going to have a hard time
castling short because
well because there's a queen here on g7
and if we're able to get a rook anyone
that will spell
immediate doom for black and
obviously if this doesn't work out we
might pay the price for it our king is
going to be weak
but um we're also getting this dark
squid bishop which is an important piece
to take so now
i would caution against taking with the
pawn that seems a little bit too risky
he could smoke the queen out by playing
97 and then knight f5
so let's take with the queen our queen
keeps contact with the rook that's the
important part
and now we're going to very quickly try
to get the knight and the bishop out to
get a rook on e1 that's going to be the
plan
no exactly brandon okay
so which of these two pieces should we
develop first that depends on what he
does
queen c7 is yeah that's something we
could consider
i would hesitate you know to grab pawns
with the queen because we haven't
developed
but certainly if he plays um
you know if he misplays this we might
want to take that pawn as well his best
move here
is to play knight g8 to e7 that's a very
strong developing move
and i think black is totally fine here
but it's a hard position to play it goes
c6 and i think that's a mistake i think
he's mis-evaluating the danger
i think he doesn't realize how close we
are to bringing a rook to e1
now how should we start should we
develop the bishop first with tempo
maybe
or should we get our night out very
important to consider things concretely
don't just play bishop d3 because it's
with tempo
consider this the specifics of the
position bishop d3 would be bad because
it hangs the pawn
so we have to play knight f3 first
right you always want to consider the
specifics um
you know the general reasoning is
important too but
always check for hanging pawns and stuff
like that it's important to catch
yourself i think when you're reasoning
based
on general on sort of general ideas
that's
often a lead up to a blunder
okay so d5 and now we're winning now
the knight intercepts the queen so
obviously we play the move bishop d3
and there are two threats that he has to
deal with the first is of course rookie
one
the second what's the second threat that
now looms
uh looms over him the second is bishop
takes g6
and as i explained yesterday this is a
type 2 undefended piece our queen is
making contact with the rook
and we had to notice this when we played
queen takes c3 you know i made this
mental note to myself that the queen
hasn't lost
touch with the rook and
now we will reap that reward
yeah this was a nice little segment here
and at this level you can see that
players generally are a lot better at
making sense of complications but in the
in the heat of the moment
they still you know miscalculate and
underestimate the danger sometimes
this is resignable yeah this is
resignable
okay why not bishop b5 so bishop b5
uh is a is a fancy move but it doesn't
come with tempo i think that's the main
issue
bishop d3 attacks his queen whereas
bishop b5 he could ignore that bishop
and cover up the e file also
the bishop is going to make contact with
that he finds a very strong defensive
move d4 is super
strong i think i missed that that's the
only way
that he stays alive and he's still in
very very big trouble and his idea is
that if we play knight takes d4
he is going to play the move bishop g4
check
and he gets his pieces out very very
quickly i don't like that
we have several options we can thank you
scotcho we can play
bishop takes c4 and get a better end
game we can play queen takes b4
and get an end game upon up we can also
move the queen somewhere then we'll have
to lose touch with the rook
but on the flip side we maintain a huge
initiative so where should we put the
queen
well let's consider where he's going to
put his queen and try to decide
accordingly
i think one of the better options here
is to bring the queen up to c5
bring the queen up to c5 you know for
maximal pressure on his position if that
makes sense
there there were many other good moves
and queen b4 was good too
now in your mind you should already be
entertaining the prospect of trading
queens and getting a much better end
game
if he plays queen d5 which is the most
accurate move i think that that's
exactly what we're going to do
but we're going to try to do it in the
best possible way
rookie one he would take our queen i
wasn't a huge fan of that
rookie one was possible but he would
just take our queen and we're much
better in the end game but i think this
is more ambitious
yeah this guy is good this guy is this
guy is legit
he's in trouble he's still in very very
big trouble his queen is only three
squares he can go here
now before taking the queen is there a
move that we could throw in
that's certainly not going to hurt thank
you adiar for the prime we could throw
in the move
rookie one check let's see what he does
because if he covers the check with the
bishop or if you cover yeah and that's a
blunder
and this loses the game because as you
can see we have this pawn on f4 we can
play f5 but not before trading queens
if i was playing bran and i blundered
the queen but first we take the queen
then we play a five and we win a piece
yeah and the game is over well defended
by black
but he's unable to contain the
initiative in the end
oh he absolutely played well he found a
lot of good defensive resources but it's
not going to be enough
yeah okay knight f4 and he collapses
we take the knight of course and then we
take the bishop yeah
look at how all of our pieces are so
nice according the king on d1
that was the money decision because we
ended up bringing the rook d1 and that
one is the game
yeah yeah i mean at this point it
doesn't really matter
i would say miniature is like 15 moves
in under yeah
it's it's on the doorstep of a miniature
doesn't really matter any resigns good
game
okay so this was interesting e4 e5 d4
knight c6
and de-95 yeah that's a great points guy
so knight c3 right very flexible move
let's see how he develops before we
decide on
uh the strategy for kicking this knight
away and we've previously faced knight
f6
now f4 is much stronger because first of
all the queen's pathway to f to h4 is
blocked and second of all most
importantly
after knight g6 um i've talked about
this previously when you develop your
pieces without moving any pawns
those pieces become very vulnerable to
getting trampled over
uh by sort of a a simple pawn storm
so the movie five is incredibly nasty
the knight has no squares here
it's got to drop back to g8 and now we
have a huge development advantage and a
massive center
so now we're going to play bishop c4 on
castle and blow black off the board we
had a game like this
early in the speed run i think all right
so bishop b4 is definitely good and now
we go for this
queen d4 idea which i which is probably
not objectively the best
and alternatively knight f3 is
very much possible and if he takes on c3
we tell him congratulations
you've damaged our pawn structure but
now we've got the two bishops and i
think we've got a nice position here so
that would be a more
positional option even bishop d2 is fine
this is not very active but
there's nothing wrong with this move
either so queen d4
queen to e7 and again if he drops the
knight back to defend the bishop he
drops the spawn
now this doesn't win the rook okay this
doesn't win the rook because as many of
you indicated there is the move queen f6
and after the queen trade we get a you
know we get an endgame upon
up this is not terrible for black but
we'll take it
um 2700 blitz in three months okay
that is a bit odd and bishop c3 queen c3
is a big win for us as well
so he plays queen e7 we got four so
knight g6 is
really the only move to my eyes knight
g6 we would play queen takes g7 and
again he'd have to go queen g7
by the way here see there's a subtle
difference if he takes on e4 in this
position
uh could somebody tell me why king d1 is
now a mistake and how should white
respond here
because the circumstances have changed
now we're no longer trying to get rook
to one the priority now is to win this
rook
because he's forfeited his ability to
play queen f6
but those of you with sharp tactical
vision will see
what move for black here there's a
saving resource
this king of course is very vulnerable
to checks
not 94 94 94 is interesting but
i'm thinking along the lines of queen d4
forcing the queen trade and black is
fine
so instead of this having calculated
that line you need to tell yourself okay
queen d4 is a threat that's a defensive
threat can we cover that square while
blocking the check we actually can
knight g to e2
and the rook i believe is lost here
okay so using logic in these positions
is very much possible
just because the position is complicated
doesn't mean you have to over complicate
it
all right so knight g6 and
queen takes g7 we go for it queen takes
c4 check
and now the key move and skype brought
up a good point
players at this level often have a hard
time and players at all levels have a
hard time
making moves to voluntarily lose
castling rights any move
with the king in the opening that's not
castles is
often played with a heavy heart and
often it should be
you often don't want to play you know
bon cloud type move or king f1
but the better you get the more
comfortable you have to be with
violating uh principles and rules and
the more comfortable you have to get
with
you know with with prioritizing
concrete considerations over uh your
comfort level and your general
principles
so i've shown previously
one of my favorite games on this topic
is the game between karpov and kamsky
uh this was a very famous game where
karpov came up with this brilliant
novelty and a karo khan
that really took the chess world by
storm this is 1993
and in this very peaceful karo khan
position
karpov comes up with he comes up with an
insane idea
um it's just like a regular car con
nothing seems to be going on
okay we're fine does anybody remember
perhaps uh
what anatoly karpov played in this
position
he plays king e7 exactly good job what's
the idea the idea is to connect
the queen and the rook sorry that was
wrong and that was wrong the idea is to
connect the queen and the rook
why is that important well what karpov
recognized is the queen on h4 is
actually in a lot of trouble and black
is threatening the move g5
which literally traps the queen white
will have to sacrifice on g5 and if the
king was on e8 here then obviously this
would not be possible because the rook
would be hanging
so he's preparing g5 and it's
tremendously difficult to stop this move
kamsky finds the only way knight e5 the
idea is to pave
uh is to create the g3 escape square for
the queen
but this ends up losing a pawn how can
karfog went upon here and another pretty
typical tactic in this position this
occurs in some other openings too
notice that this diagonal is open and
whenever this diagonal is open you
always have to keep an eye out for queen
a5 related
ideas so the immediate queen a5
is not accurate because of bishop d2 so
first you take on e5
d e and now queen a5 picks off the pawn
and white has
insufficient compensation here there is
there is compensation well
you know black's king is vulnerable but
karpov ended up winning the game
so uh very very impressive stuff and
this was found without the gate of
computers because this was 1993.
why not queen a3 um
oh so queen h3 yeah so queen h3 uh you
have g4
that's a good point g4 winning the night
okay
all right i think that's an unpopular
opinion
for good reason so anyways uh that was
just a good example that's one of my
favorite examples of doing this kind of
kind of thing and here the consideration
is different but it's
just as concrete we want to get a rook
to e1 that's one of our main sources of
pressure and so the fastest way to do
that is to bring the king out to d1 we
don't want anything
on uh we don't want anything on on
the e file other than other than a rook
oh my god
damn girl ten thousander just wanted to
say thank you for all that you do your
teaching is unmatched and i wouldn't be
the chess player i am today without you
fan
that is incredibly sweet and incredibly
generous thank you for the 10 000 holy
smokes
can you believe that what
thank you shadow that means a lot to me
thank you thank you
that's crazy
you don't have 10k bits then get out
thank you so much that's incredibly
awesome
wow that's just i am perpetually spoiled
all right so what were the indicators
that king move was the appropriate move
well
the indicator was there was only one
there were two indicators the first
is well that's you know the c2 pawn
hangs and this move defends the pawn
but that's not as important right we
often sacrifice pawns
the most important thing is that i
noticed and there's three things
the other thing is that king d1 uh
unpins the knight and so he has to deal
with threat
and in these super complicated positions
every tempo matters
every tempo is important but the main
thing is that i noticed the queen and
the king were on the same file
i know because of the presence of this
queen that he's nowhere near being able
to castle
and so the possibility of putting the
rook on e1 is a lot scarier because he's
far away from castling
so king d1 all of these considerations
together
uh warrants making this somewhat
weakening move
so bishop c3 queen c3 and now he made
the decisive mistake c6 that's just too
slow
and had he understood what i was trying
to accomplish or he would have played
the move knight eight to e7
and the idea is that he does prepare to
castle as quickly as possible
now white is better here we go knight f3
he castles we go bishop d3 we've got the
two bishops
his king is still very weak but at least
his queen is intact and the game goes on
queen c6
and and you know the game continues um
so instead he goes c6 and that's a
little bit of a short-sighted move right
he's afraid that we're going to take the
pun
but it's all about priorities here he
shouldn't be worried about losing this
pawn
because he's just got greater fish to
fry
and i wouldn't take the pawn because he
castles and the knight d5 comes with
tempo
i wouldn't grab that pawn we would
prioritize our development in this case
isn't black castling without the g-pawn
a bad idea well that's like
you know you don't get to choose here
right you you can't always have a
perfect worlds
and when your king is in this amount of
danger you've got to take what you can
get and
is the king safe on the king side no is
it a lot safer than it is on e8
absolutely
right it's all relative you can't use
the sort of
um sort of a global standard for judging
castling
it's always about the concrete
properties of the position
c6 knight f3 d5 bishop d3 and now d4
very nice move very nice move um
again if he moves this queen back we go
rookie one or we can take on g6 it
doesn't matter and when the rook
but rookie one is also possible bishop
e6 and f5
we have a choice of ways to win material
he goes d4 and queen c5
so again his problem is that if he goes
queen e7
once again rookie one comes in and if he
goes bishop e6 it may appear that black
is well black is on the verge of
covering up
the pressure what is white's simplest
path to victory here
so we can we can't take the queen but it
doesn't quite win a piece
amazingly i would just go queen takes d4
i would go queen takes d4
again creating all this pressure but we
could also take uh take his queen
and if he plays knight eight takes c7 we
go
f5 anyway takes takes and the knight is
immobilized
and his correct move would be knight g6
takes c7 because f5 meets with bishop
even somehow he's still alive
we can't play f6 so he's he keeps his
pieces intact
but the simplest is just to play knight
takes d4 and we've got
an amazing end game we're upon up his
pieces are in ruins
so something like this perhaps would be
black's most resilient option
so queen d5 rookie one check and now if
he plays knight e7 the situation is
changed his knight is a sitting duck so
we take his queen
we go f5 and then we go f6 winning the
piece
this is pretty simple it all revolves
around e-file pressure bishop b6 take
stakes f5
and it's over